-Today the house held
its third day
of public impeachment hearings
and heard from two witnesses
with firsthand knowledge
of President Trump's phone call
with the president of Ukraine.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
It is safe to say that,
politically speaking,
these hearings have been
very bad for President Trump.
70% of Americans now say
Trump's actions towards Ukraine
were wrong and,
since impeachment began,
Trump has campaigned
for two Republican candidates
in deep red states,
both of whom lost.
Trump even specifically
told voters in those states
that he needed them
to vote Republican
to send a message
that they still support him.
-The headlines the next day:
"Trump Took Loss."
I lift 'em up a lot.
So Trump took loss, so you gotta
give me a big win, please, okay?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Okay?
-Why does he talk
to his own supporters
like they're children?
[ Laughter ]
He sounds like
a degenerate gambler
who bet on his kid's
Little League game.
[as Trump]
"Come on, Tyler.
You've gotta give
Daddy a win.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you don't think
you can get a hit,
just lean in
and take a pitch
off your noggin, Tyler.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We need this, Tyler.
[ Applause and cheering ]
And Trump's reaction
to the impeachment hearing
has only made things worse.
Last week, Trump attacked the
former ambassador to Ukraine,
Marie Yovanovitch, on Twitter,
during her testimony,
which legal analysts said could
constitute witness tampering.
So, in advance
of today's hearing,
anchors on Trump's favorite
TV channel, Fox News,
begged him not to tweet, or even
watch the hearings at all.
-If I were Trump, I wouldn't
even talk about impeachment.
I wouldn't tweet about it.
-President should just ignore
this whole thing.
Don't tweet during it.
Don't get outraged over it.
It ticks ya off.
-Think about that:
Fox News anchors
are telling the president
to ignore the hearings,
[ Laughter ]
even though Fox News
is airing those same
impeachment hearings.
[ Laughter ]
Fox is telling viewers not
to watch them.
Soon, they're gonna put up
a banner that says,
"Change the channel.
Nickelodeon has cartoons."
[ Laughter and applause ]
At this point, Trump's aides
are gonna have to distract him
from the hearings by sending him
on a scavenger hunt.
"Okay, Donald, there's
a free chicken nugget
hidden somewhere
in the White House.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[as Trump] Oh. Oh, I bet it's
in the secret vault where we hid
the incriminating phone call
with the president of Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
I'm comin' for you, nugget.
In fact, the public hearings
are going so badly for Trump
that Republicans
who spent weeks complaining
the initial depositions
were being held in private
are now going back
to say this should all be
handled behind closed doors.
Here is Wisconsin
Senator Ron Johnson on Sunday.
-One thing I wanna point out is
the damage that's being done
to our country through this
entire impeachment process.
Those individuals
that leaked this, you know,
if their interest was a stronger
relationship with Ukraine,
they didn't accomplish this.
Having this all come out
in the public
has weakened that relationship.
It has exposed things that
didn't need to be exposed.
So, this would have been
far better off
if we woulda just taken care
of this behind the scenes.
-Oh, would that have been
better for you?
Now that it's embarrassing,
[ Laughter ]
you want to take care of it
behind the scenes?
[ Laughter, clapping ]
What does that even mean?
"Look, let's just settle
this in private
over a few beers
with an arm wrestling contest.
Whoever wins --
Oh, damn it!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[as Trump]
Best of luck Nancy. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Damn you, baby arms.
[ Fresh laughter ]
And after
this morning's hearing,
you can see why Republicans
wanted to handle impeachment
behind the scenes: Because it's
been devastating for them.
Today's first witnesses
were Jennifer Williams,
the Russia advisor
to Vice President Mike Pence,
who's worked for other
Republican presidents;
and Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Vindman,
the top Ukraine expert
on the National Security Council
and a decorated war veteran.
They both heard
Trump's phone call
with the president of Ukraine.
Vindman, for example,
said he reported the call
out of a sense of duty
because it was inappropriate
and improper.
Both witnesses
could also provide
direct firsthand knowledge
of even the smallest details
from the phone calls,
like, for example,
the languages that were spoken.
-July 25th
at approximately 9:00 am.
You both were sitting
in the situation room
and you were preparing
for a long-awaited phone call
between President Trump
and President Zelensky.
Do you recall what language
President Zelensky spoke
on this July 25th phone call?
-I know he made a valiant
effort to speak English.
He'd been practicing up
his English.
-Now, of course,
he could've been referring
to the president of Ukraine
or the president
of the United States.
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. Chairman,
President Trump
tried to brush up on his
English, but, unfortunately,
he still hasn't learned how
to spell his own name
right in tweets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[as Trump] Hello.
This is President Tehtum.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, of the united to dates.
[ Fresh laughter ]
Williams also testified directly
about what she heard
on that call and she said that
she was concerned about it.
-I found the July 25th
phone call unusual because,
in contrast to other
presidential calls
I had observed,
it involved discussion
of what appeared to be
a domestic political matter.
-That's right.
The call was unusual,
both because the president
of the United States pressured
a foreign country to interfere
in the 2020 election
and also because
it was Donald Trump
and everything he does
is unusual.
Even the way he poses
for photos is unusual.
I mean --
[ Laughter ]
Look at him.
He sways back and forth
[ Laughter and applause ]
like a 10-year-old
who really has to pee.
[as Trump] Uh, uh,
Pence told you to go
before the picture.
Why didn't you listen?
Why didn't you listen and go
before the picture?
[ Laughter ]
Now, Williams is an advisor
to the vice president
of the United States
and she heard the call herself
and, yet,
Trump attacked her Sunday,
on Twitter, writing,
"Tell Jennifer Williams
whoever that is,
to read BOTH transcripts
of the presidential calls."
What do you mean,
"whoever that is"?
She's an advisor
to the vice president.
Soon, Trump's
gonna start pretending
he never even met Mike Pence.
[as Trump] "Oh, that guy?
I thought that guy was
a Halloween decoration.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I --
I put a bucket of candy in his
lap for trick-or-treaters.
[ Fresh laughter ]
Now, in advance of the hearings,
Republicans have tried
to impugn the integrity
and character
of Lieutenant Colonel Vindman.
Yesterday, for example,
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson,
who we mentioned earlier,
wrote a letter
suggesting Vindman was
trying to sabotage Trump,
although he had
no proof, whatsoever.
-Johnson writes this:
"A significant number
of bureaucrats and staff members
within the executive branch
have never accepted
President Trump as legitimate
and resent his unorthodox style
and his intrusion
onto their 'turf.'
They react by leaking
to the press and participating
in the ongoing effort
to sabotage his policies
and, if possible,
remove him from office.
It is entirely possible that
Vindman fits this profile."
-You think he's trying
to sabotage Trump?
The only person who's trying
to sabotage Donald Trump
is Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, the guy commits crimes,
then goes on TV
and confesses to them.
Honestly, there's a chance
he's trying to get impeached
so he can collect unemployment.
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] Check it out.
Now that I've been fired,
I get two weeks severance,
plus COBRA.
[ Laughter ]
Conservatives on Fox
and elsewhere
have also claimed that,
because Vindman speaks Ukrainian
and because he came here
as a refugee
when he was three years old,
he somehow has more
of an allegiance to Ukraine
than the United States.
For example, the GOP lawyer
assigned to question Vindman
brought up a job offer
Vindman had apparently received
from a Ukrainian official,
a job offer Vindman
immediately dismissed as comical
and reported to his superiors.
-Did Mr. Danylyuk offer you
a position of defense minister
-[Laughs]
-with the Ukrainian government?
-He did.
-And how many times
did he do that?
-I believe it was three times.
-And do you have any reason
why he asked you to do that?
-I don't know, but, every
single time, I dismissed it.
-When he made this offer
to you initially,
did you leave the door open?
Was there a reason
that he had to come back
and ask a second and third time,
or was he just trying
to convince ya?
-Counsel, you know what?
The whole notion
is rather comical.
I did not leave the door
open at all.
-When he made this offer to you,
was he speaking in English
or Ukrainian?
-Oh, Mr. Danylyuk
is a absolutely flawless
English speaker.
He was speaking in English.
-And that would be memorable,
of course, 'cause it's rare
for anyone
in the Trump White House
to hear someone speak
flawless English.
I mean, Trump knows
like five words,
Pence doesn't speak at all,
and I'm pretty sure
[ Laughter ]
Stephen Miller only communicates
in demonic screams.
[ Fresh laughter ]
How are ya, Stephen?
-Aaaaaaaaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
It's true.
You are a racist.
[ Laughter ]
But, today
during the hearing,
Vindman courageously rebuffed
any suggestion
that he was somehow loyal
to any country other
than the U.S.
and there was one moment
where he reminded
GOP Congressman Devin Nunes
of his Army rank.
-Mr. Vindman, you testified
in your deposition
that you did not know
the whistleblower.
-Ranking Member, it's Lieutenant
Colonel Vindman, please.
-Lieutenant Colonel Vindman.
-[as Nunes] Uh uh uh uh -- D'oh!
[ Laughter ]
Ih ooh uh.
Look at Nunes' face.
I'd say he's bewildered,
but he always looks like that.
[ Laughter ]
Nunes looks like a waiter
who just realized
he forgot the specials.
[ Laughter ]
[as Nunes]
Uh, uh, we --
Huhhhh.
[ Laughter ]
We have a fish.
It, um --
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
It -- It come--
It comes on a plate.
[ Laughter ]
Now, while this was happening,
Trump was asked
about Vindman's testimony
and Trump claimed he had
no idea who Vindman was.
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
-Thank you for asking.
-I don't know him.
I don't know, as he says,
the Lieutenant Colonel.
I understand somebody
had the misfortune
of calling him mister
and he corrected them.
I never saw the man.
I understand, now,
he wears his uniform
when he goes in.
No, I don't know Vindman at all.
But Vindman, I watched him
for a little while this morning
and I think he --
I'm gonna let people make
their own determination,
but I don't know Vindman.
I never heard of him.
-What?
You never heard of him?!
I mean, it's one thing
to say you've never met him,
but he's been
in the news for weeks!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I've never watched
"The Masked Singer,"
but I know it's a TV show.
[ Laughter, clapping ]
During his Q&A with reporters,
Trump also attacked
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
for moving forward
with impeachment.
-The woman is
grossly incompetent.
All she wants to do
is focus on impeachment,
which is just a little
pipe dream she's got.
What's going on is a disgrace
and it's an embarrassment
to our nation
and, in the meantime,
we can't get USMCA approved
because Nancy Pelosi
is grossly incompetent.
She is incompetent.
-She's incompetent?!
You failed
at almost everything
you've done in your life.
You won an election where
you got the second-most votes
and you spend most of your time
wandering in circles
around the White House lawn,
[ Laughter ]
like a kid waiting for his mom
to pick him up from school.
[ Fresh laughter and applause ]
I mean, look at him.
Look at that.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I thought he had
his own helicopter.
He looks like he's
waitin' for the bus.
[ Laughter ]
He should be takin' a drag
off a cigarette, goin',
"Screw it.
I'm walkin'.
The MTA sucks."
[ Laughter and applause ]
When their attacks on Vindman's
credibility didn't work,
GOP Congressman John Ratcliffe
shifted tactics
and tried to claim
that no one who testified
had ever specifically
used the word bribery
in any of their depositions.
-No witness
has used the word bribery
to describe
President Trump's conduct.
None of them.
These aren't all of the
deposition transcripts.
These are just the ten
that have been released.
The number of times witnesses
have used the word
bribery or bribe
to describe
President Trump's conduct
in the last six weeks
of this inquiry is zero.
-That's right.
He can't be guilty
because they didn't use
that exact word?
Republicans must spend all their
time reading the Federal Code,
looking for crimes
Trump isn't guilty of.
"Let's see here.
Extortion? Guilty.
Uh, fraud?
Oh, he's guilty on that.
What about speeding?
Has he ever run a red light?
Damn it!"
[ Laughter ]
Once again,
this hearing proved
that Republicans
have no defense.
All they can do is
attack the witnesses
because that's what Trump wants.
I wouldn't be surprised if Trump
called Republicans and Fox News
before the hearing and said...
-You gotta give me
a big win, please, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]